la crise du coc vide un impact
considérable sur l'économie mais s'il ya
bien une frange de la population qui la
subit de plein fouet c'est la jeunesse
contrats courts arrêté jobs étudiants de
plus en plus difficiles à trouver et
insertion dans le monde professionnel
particulièrement délicate la situation
des jeunes est préoccupante
conséquence ces images que l'on peut
voir depuis plusieurs semaines en france
des files d'attentes d'étudiants
contraint de recourir aux aides
alimentaires
alors comment répondre à cette détresse
des jeunes c'est une question sur
laquelle s'est penché un comité
d'experts présidé par l'ancien patron de
renault louis schweitzer comité qui
évalue la stratégie gouvernementale de
lutte contre la pauvreté dans le cadre
d'un rapport plus large qui pointent
notamment l'absence de clarté et
d'efficacité d'un certain nombre de
mesures prises par l'exécutif ces
dernières années le comité s'inquiète
aussi de la situation des jeunes
une étude effectuée sur une période
antérieure à la crise du coronavirus
mais qui ne sont voit que conforté par
la situation actuelle
par exemple le rapport s'étonne du fait
que le rsa le revenu minimum en france
ne soit pas accessible aux plus jeunes
contrairement à ce que font beaucoup
d'autres pays de l'union européenne
quant à l'argument affirmant qu'un tel
dispositif découragerait les jeunes à
chercher un emploi
il n'est pas confirmé par les travaux
existants selon les auteurs du rapport
qui demande donc une politique plus
ambitieuse
l'argument balayé dans cet extrait est
en fait celui du gouvernement s'opposant
à l'ouverture du rsa aux 18-25 ans le
ministre de l'économie préfère insister
sur une meilleure insertion
professionnelle à 18 ans ce qu'on veut
c'est un travail on veut une
rémunération de son travail
on ne veut pas une allocation une
formule qui avait été vivement critiquée
notamment à gauche beaucoup de
dirigeants politiques de gauche milite
activement pour l'instauration de ce rsa
jeune et c'est donc aussi le cas de ce
comité d'évaluation de lutte contre la
pauvreté
un comité affiliés à l'organisme francs
stratégie est donc rattaché à matignon
le comité d'évaluation recommande donc
d'expérimenter un revenu de base pour
les jeunes en études en emplois peu
rémunérés ou en recherche d'emploi de 18
à 24 ans sous conditions de ressources
et en prenant en compte la solidarité
familiale sous réserve que le
jeunes puissent en bénéficier en juillet
2020 le gouvernement lançait son plan un
jeune une solution un dispositif visant
notamment à faciliter leur embauche
mais huit mois plus tard et alors que la
crise perdure force est de constater
qu'à un grand nombre de jeunes sont
toujours sans solution